okay what do we have here what do we
have here that will recognize oh oh wait
I do i do this looks like a circus it's
so weird but the way that moves in a
crunch yes i am very ideal of that
crouch oh what the [ __ ] oh yeah oh shet
shet shet on our [ __ ] up what is this
little lot of our services
oh I can drop savers your time
yeah you kept all its oh [ __ ] hey it's
me dropsy mmm damn big oh ok press the
eye on that oh oh my grunt your dad
that's a little [ __ ] up how's my irish
car thing oh [ __ ] he's extremely music
[ __ ] like today's they're burning the TV
area oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] my ass home who
could have done this and is it okay is
it oh [ __ ]
what happen here it accepted my loins
they get better just a dream Oh
everything's back to normal my dogs here
too long a li that Oh everyone is happy
anyway what's a TVA what's a DV five
years
five years one
oh it's my fixed organ oh it sounds
great yet hello
basic like Heather Kevin
every church for him
oh [ __ ] i can make
[ __ ] it could be different things that
came out of a job salary jobs
let's go not all right hair think it's a
[ __ ] plane up that a cake that
Samantha of course future labe never set
though what is that like late
I love your up saying
you
it's a good one
I still get stopped everything up still
a [ __ ] stomach acid are gonna
watching up oh
beautiful
ok
hey hello bird bottom job say hello
forget the [ __ ] out of here I got bells
away Oh baby
just a [ __ ] dog
[ __ ]
take this and upper right there yes you
say [ __ ] that idea oh it belongs those
things it's hungry okay so a little
wanna worry I got you
shovel some [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that
oh no i just used to it's the birthday
party person has done I need a present
to walk to a [ __ ] awesome it should be
ok ok
ok
oh I forgot she's dead when she died I
get fast show vehicle at the walk there
but we crash travel to a
now you bash a question
oh you gotta be a [ __ ] doggy you can
together that clearly how are you baby I
got [ __ ] away love you okay Oh drop
something Oh
they were booked a book or some other
grounds yes
sorry doctor I'll take that [ __ ] up okay
do with your wares
oh sure
hey socko
show like that show like that yeah go
[ __ ] yourself
had to say
easy
[ __ ] you
oh okay she wasn't sick [ __ ] you
dog it is that they [ __ ] up do what you
do best on the site
look at how extent
but this thing is like again
I'm not there yet
shut he hates cops
at her die
Oh
here so let's get it here's a [ __ ]
ice cream
oh yeah unlock this region
why don't think I can get this guy
[ __ ] that
I guess I just [ __ ] free running
[ __ ] yourself No
you
very sad
you
at the icic
yeah I guess you gotta go left our walls
all I got to say
[ __ ] all you guys stop pills like the
clouds here okay this is really one
place left to go to dr. Inglis
[ __ ] out of here get the [ __ ] out of
here so this is the hospital
magic
no [ __ ] up later
I was compressing game I've ever played
now we all can't nice life
he's like there's the bits there
get the [ __ ] ever [ __ ]
why does every drop say hey drop see
I think so
but on this
none
yes yes
Oh
okay hey got Lenny [ __ ] got no money
this [ __ ]
obviously this is like the worst I'll
check if you ever play
anything
for God's away
ok
okay good piss on that is all that [ __ ]
yourself aliens whistles call the entire
era and you get whistle equals money
okay um thank you
hey yeah well these are they two wars
controls have everyone oh no get the
[ __ ] okay okay always [ __ ] all right
Lisa battalions here I need a whistle
though I'm just like a little clown like
you don't mind rag hey what the [ __ ]
knows wasn't there that I have all guy
do what you do best oh it's not here the
[ __ ] cemetery I ready for this real [ __ ]
yeah
what the [ __ ] is this oh yeah you
[ __ ] soil okay no not this guy it's a
bug oh no you're less stinky sock right
is it okay um thanks okay guys I'm going
to the cemetery yes Jesus has sad let me
move those are cut he says if you
[ __ ] psycho
okay oh this is still the alien places
in the cemetery oh good i'm here okay
agent shut okay don't touch I get it I
get it okay doc be on the ship like a
point of this into the seeker girls okay
all right okay
hands with the [ __ ] why does it all
Hayley where the [ __ ] I am let's go
though and it's cool okay really not
sure what that does let's wipe up with
the [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] I think I get
that one girl likes music her like
[ __ ] an ark estate thing so now it's
just there oh there's the grave right
there oh wait you the [ __ ] is that
that's weird I like offer it something
hey did no I can't be another thing is
that my home yeah okay okay so I've
explored a lot faster now nice actually
um
you see this Punk's you go up that way
yeah wait that wow this place is [ __ ]
huge I need to get I oh sorry Matt
Dillon check if anything I can use to
open the shift and nope that I can use
where the [ __ ] am I going ok this one
likes being cute and this one likes
music oh I think this one wants music oh
hey what's that you got there something
badass wow wow
oh did I put on the chicken thing
doesn't a [ __ ] did i'll taste yet I
don't like floating romance want this
wow she's like what the [ __ ] is that hey
try something else here I got all bag of
tricks right all right did not work well
did not work well what was that place oh
it's flowers right there ok give me some
those flowers yes ok you got it baby
let's go give that [ __ ] from flowers oh
[ __ ] are you okay claims now hug this
[ __ ] Wow success uh he says I'm good
and I got in there is that yes sweet
tape ok boot up a little bit a bit a bit
a bit of Buddha Buddha Buddha the Buddha
Buddha but yeah yeah how what if i give
the chicken here
yeah yeah dance dance dance yeah he's
like I felt like I done and I don't
really know I don't really know can i
pls this Jason lots of [ __ ] gone yeah
let me see what was derelict for may I
success yeah you're cool with me nice a
guy get the other bit she'll shake long
I just like hug her and get her [ __ ]
hip is a bummer quick
hmm she was like oh is this [ __ ] huh
anything I got here that could get her
attention she wants chairs OMP seats oh
wait that's all can do it now
see what I see what you got talk two
more two more or more [ __ ] more what
was out there oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
dog get it now I thought can't they [ __ ]
what's in there that's Church trying to
tell me to look in there and they get in
there yeah there boy and there how I
[ __ ] it in there
I'm not nearly small enough see
grandma's [ __ ] crotch now we can ask
ranaut which should they go on their
[ __ ] close all right keep on going I
guess Nona wreck that like salesman guy
take some strange [ __ ] going on here
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] you got this way
do you ever even close now though hey
what's in there oh it's this [ __ ] she's
so hungry I have any food for her yeah
they were yelling at her [ __ ] just
missed that oh you're happy [ __ ] give
her sock [ __ ] her with the sock who's
that oh [ __ ] they bleed me for like all
the murder
don't want to go in there get chicken
thing look at me I'm the chicken so this
guy am no [ __ ] he put his pants on I'll
put on that chicken thing right now to
it does it is [ __ ] Oh heavy metal [ __ ]
oh it's like nine o'clock at night
here's that crazy guy let's [ __ ] go
who's that having pants oh that's a what
is it okay the devil [ __ ] a where's
got one for me no money no bunker ok I
got a lot of weird [ __ ] heck no uh-huh
sick [ __ ] ok he's like a painter right
with this painting look I want pho your
[ __ ] ass off okay we got cemeteries
pay my respects you know
is that what's on the ground they're all
[ __ ] here huh okay okay dig up that body
[ __ ] what is that this is the weirdest
game ever now go take that flower Hill
oh [ __ ] oh I complain a new flower for
that girl okay there we go I mean that
one girl that oh that's the one hey go
baby there you go
very cute baby very cute pay your
respects little dog Oh put that stock of
that grave for him okay hello hey really
okay
okay I've got back I'm back he's happy
he's happy let's get to it 10 okay hey
that's okay he's like okay Josie okay
yeah we're gonna pause it there we've
been doing pretty good and let's keep
that one far for good luck maybe a call
in a couple thank you oh yeah sorry
chachos